antoine un mal français que l'on connaît
au niveau de notre économie en général
c'est la fiscalité
ce sont les charges que penses tu de
cette fiscalité et notamment comment
vois-tu une nouvelle fist fiscalité
agricole pour alléger bien évidemment
les charges de nos agriculteurs
merci merci à ces témoignages sur tous
et merci à cette initiative de notre
formation politique et qui est
indispensable dans la situation de crise
que notre avance et remet en parler du
fiscalité je crois qu'il faut déjà
marqué ce qui nous différencie par
rapport à la gauche
je me suis amusé hier soir tardivement
encore rédigé un petit papier parce que
je crois que les est important de se
mettre d'accord sur les mots qu'est-ce
que l'agriculture pour nous à droite
très clairement les agriculteurs sont
des entrepreneurs et nous venons
d'entendre à gauche
les agriculteurs sont des quasi
fonctionnaires de l'agro écologie qui
répondent à une commande publique de
produits du terroir
c'est sympathique de protection de la
nature d'animation des milieux ruraux et
donc le seul débat qu'on a eues ces
quatre dernières années autour de cette
notion d'activités agricoles c'était de
savoir comment on utilise les aides de
la pac pour donner un salaire aux
agriculteurs l'aspect économique
production nada complètement zappé
complètement zappé deuxième chose qu'il
est important de rappeler ça a été dit
c'est la question de la rupture
familiale
on n'entend plus que ça dans l'hémicycle
de l'assemblée nationale arrive du
familia la culture familiale
mais dès que vous prononcez il m'arrive
de faire le mode société alors là vous
êtes le diable
or en réalité c'est bien là où la droite
est à une vision réaliste des situations
la société est au service
la forme sociétaire est au service de la
famille elle permet le développement de
l'entreprise elle permet d'installer un
conjoint ou un jeune agriculteur et
permet surtout ça a été rappelé tout à
l'heure de séparer le patrimoine privé
du patrimoine professionnel en cas de
difficultés c'est un élément clé
donc la société est un outil ce n'est
pas une fin en soi et je crois qu'il est
important de le rappeler lorsqu'on parle
fiscalité il faut l'avoir en tête
pourquoi l'agriculture est une activité
risquée bas tout le monde le sait parce
qu'il ya des aléas climatiques idéales
et de marché mais je crois qu'il faut
surtout contre battre cette idée qui est
battue par la gauche de dire attention
c'est la faute au gouvernement de droite
qui sont des ultra libéraux qui ont tous
démontré la da da da da da faut le dire
en france et je le regrette qu'on soit
pas assez présent et on y reviendra tout
à l'heure dans le débat européen parce
qu'on a une plus value apportée dans ce
débat en france nous sommes pas des
libéraux est celui qui me dit français
et qu'il est libéral cet inventeur nous
sommes des colbertiste nous avons la
culture de l'intervention de l'état et
c'est bien pour cette raison
qu'aujourd'hui les agriculteurs
s'adresse au gouvernement en disant
faites quelque chose
ce qu'il nous faut réinventer je crois
que la droite est la mieux passé pour le
faire c'est une espèce de neo
colbertisme on perd mais cette
combinaison entre acteurs privés et
acteurs publics pour permettre la
réussite de notre économie c'est ça
qu'il nous faut reformuler réinventer
mais ça méritera une autre table ronde
enfin je dernier élément pourquoi être
et culture coûte cher puisque pas quand
on parle de fiscalité vous aussi posez
la question du capital alors à gauche on
nous explique qu'il suffit prend des
demandeurs d'emploi de redonner un lopin
de terre quelques z
et puis des cours du soir et puis c'est
bon on a des agriculteurs la réalité on
le sait aussi aller différentes ça
nécessite énormément de capitaux ça a
été rappelé il ya des enjeux de
transmission considérable et cette
notion de capitalisation elle est
inédite dans le paysage économique
puisque l'agriculture nécessite le plus
de capitaux par rapport aux résultats
espérés
quand on parle de fiscalité il faut
l'avoir en tête alors la proposition de
loi je vais pas vous les énumérer
on aura l'occasion je pense les revenir
dans les prochaines journées mais
s'attaque frontalement à tous ces sujets
et en particulier sur les outils fiscaux
qui existent qu'il faut améliorer des
pays des pays qui ont déjà été amélioré
mais qui qu'il faut maintenant
déplafonné il n'y a pas de raison de
considérer que c'est uniquement pour les
petites entreprises les gros sont aussi
des risques et méritent autant d'être
accompagné
il faut s'occuper de la fiscalité des
désinvestissements la question de la
traçabilité et des normes est également
abordée dans cette proposition de loi
je n'y reviens pas la question de des
investissements dans les bâtiments paul
auffray bien en parler depuis trois ans
la lecture française a marqué le pas en
matière d'investissements dans les
bâtiments or on a aujourd'hui un
dispositif qui existe le maquereau on
aime on n'aime pas le ministre mais le
dispositif me paraît intéressant sur un
mort qui cement mais qu'il est
uniquement appliqué au matériel pas au
bâtiment
la proposition de loi propose de
l'étendre aux bâtiments d'élevage
nous revenons dans la proposition de loi
support finalement aller au devant d'un
grand regret de françois hollande qui a
dit que le fait de supprimer la tva
emploi était une erreur et bien nous
corrigions cette erreur nous
rétablissons ce qui avait été voté en
2012 et qui est essentiel parce qu'elle
permet d'apporter un allègement des
charges pour les bas salaires et les bas
salaires ma ce sont tous ces emplois qui
sont notamment dans l'est dans les
abattoirs
abattre un port en france coûte 10 euros
de plus qu en allemagne
alors quand vous entendez qu'un éleveur
voilà qui fait 500 cochons aux mille
cochons
par mois il perd 10 mille 15000 euros
avoir ou ne pas avoir 10 euros au niveau
de l'abattage c'est devient essentiel la
question de la volatilité des prix est
également au sujet au coeur de cette
proposition de loi en particulier la
question de l'écrêtement des pics et
aujourd'hui dans la crise où nous sommes
de faire une mesure exceptionnelle c'est
à dire de permettre aux agriculteurs de
d'être imposées sur les revenus 2014 et
sortir de la moyenne triennale qui les
paie qui les pénalise enfin il y a des
formes d'impôt particulièrement sur moi
c'est ce que j'appelle la corvée tu l'as
dit tout à l'heure les déclarations pac
les contrôles tout la papa c'est qu'il
faut faire ce sont des heures et des
heures de travail
c'est un stress permanent pour les
agriculteurs au moment des contrôles et
je crois que effectivement là dans la
proposition de loi nous essayons d'aller
encore un peu plus loin que ne l'a fait
le sénat en matière de réduction des
normes
moi ce qui me tient le plus à coeur
c'est qu'on puisse fixer le principe d'
études d'impact sérieuses par rapport
aux différentes normes qui sont établis
il n'y a pas dans le débat parlementaire
d'études d'un pape au lieu de est ce que
ça coûte au budget de l'état
est ce que ça coûte des fonctionnaires
le reste on s'en fiche
alors que le sujet essentiel de savoir
est ce qu'une mesure est favorable au
produit intérieur brut à l'emploi ou est
ce que ne l'est pas si elle ne l'est pas
et bien il ne faut pas la prendre si
elle l'est allons-y on peut prendre
cette disposition c'est ce genre d'étude
d'impact dont nous avons besoin est là
aussi bien la proposition de loi fait un
certain nombre d'avancées voilà jeté
économiser la lecture d'un long discours
et j'ai essayé de le résumer très
succinctement le message que le bout nos
portes et demain et après demain
au sein des débats à l'assemblée
nationale